so Peter Thiel who is a supporter of Ron
DeSantis comes out and says Peter Theo
likes Ron DeSantis for president but has
one worry this is a Daily Beast story
has one worry what's the worry that
round that Peter Thiel has this is a
very smart guy Peter Republican Mega
donor Peter Thiel sees potential around
the Santa saying that the Florida
governor would make a terrific president
but he did say that he liked the
sentence as the GOP nominee with one
stipulation if he's a republican nominee
I will strongly support him in 2024 but
I do worry that focusing on the woke
issue is Ground Zero uh uh as ground
zero is not quite enough the sentences
war on wokeness has been the Crux
of his political platform as of late he
infamously touted Florida as a place
where woke goes to die in a January
speech support the anti-lgbtq policies
such as the don't don't say gay Bill law
have largely defined his tenure as
governor in fact that's it's that very
law that landed him in the ongoing feud
with Disney which has drawn the hour of
old school conservatives who uh believe
the governor shouldn't be so willing to
piss off a big Corporation okay fine so
he says this yet his friend Dave Rubin
moved his podcast here and lives in
Miami feels safe over here Dave rubin's
very close to Ron DeSantis Dave is part
of the lgbtq community as a man that
identifies himself as a gay man and we
we've had him on we were just with him I
think two weeks ago or something like
that and we like Dave a lot yeah so so
even a Peter Thiel saying this and Peter
Thiel said five years ago if I was
moving here from Silicon Valley I would
have gone a house for nothing today
whatever you paid for a house in Miami
is now four times the price there is no
point of moving from Silicon Valley here
to Miami because the houses are just as
expensive as they are in Silicon Valley
this is something the centers
so so again what what he is saying
he is saying the people that don't like
it are leaving
so this kind of validates a part of you
know that that Community the whole woke
thing I think a lot of parents are
sitting on listen he got criticism for
the whole six-week thing with the
abortion that was a a lot of Republicans
said what are you doing like I talk to
wives and mothers and they're Republican
they're conservative they said what was
the point of doing that that was like
the first time we saw he missed the Mark
when he did that you didn't need to do
that there was no winning with that did
you end up winning the biggest biggest
biggest conservative Republicans what
percentage is that five percent not ten
percent you didn't need to do that fine
that was he missed that one but in this
year parents are liking the fact that
there's somebody who has the audacity to
go up against the Disney's to go up
against what they're trying to do in
schools so there is a community that's
supporting what he's doing but even
Peter thiel's give him some criticism I
think I think Tail's wrong
I mean you look at the Double you look
at the million million vote Victory
margin for Rhonda Santa says Governor
you look at the mass Exodus from New
York and California into Florida and
then I think second place is Texas uh
Ron DeSantis is the best Governor this
country has right I agree so so me me
saying where it says on an issue of jazz
Jennings being horribly misconstrued to
imply that I'm like I think he's doing a
bad job I think he's doing a fantastic
job the question is on this one moral
issue that's been happening to go viral
what's what what's their current
position that it's too late that the
abuse that may be happening ongoing in
Florida it's too late I think the issue
is it's a it's a very very dangerous
subject you know Rhonda Sanderson
Administration are willing to to tackle
these issues loudly and clearly but not
a mainstream celebrity personality it's
too much for them they can't handle that
kind of heat I that's not a
consideration for me when it comes to an
issue Hospitality so you're saying he's
afraid to go after mainstream media you
think Jazz Jennings is that big of a
mainstream person this guy's going after
Disney
knock on the door he's causing the
greatest Miami Heat of of all time to
leave Miami bro why why why why why why
the negative reaction so heavily from
his PR people maybe maybe they have
looked at it with their legal team and
they're saying there's nothing here why
don't they say that maybe they don't
want to say it for different reasons
maybe they don't want to say it because
they're dealing with other things maybe
they're sitting there saying this isn't
something that we want to tackle right
now why not just not respond at all by
the way if there's anything I will be on
the same page with you I don't think
they have the best marketing team so so
that that's a whole different thing
where for me I think they can hire a
much better marketing team than what
they have right now will criticize that
non-stop all day you know until they
either hero or they do something about
it this marketing team is not going to
take him to the next level they need a
real market like you need to have real
marketers they don't have marketing
they're playing the the safe game just
too protective and it's kind of like let
it rip let's go so anyways when when
Trump was facing the indictment Ron
DeSantis if I here's what I do if I was
governor and I'm not saying I'm right
about everything you can say I'm wrong I
got up at the podium and say mark my
words there will not be an uh an
extradition of Donald Trump from my
state no finger will be laid on this man
and thank you and have a nice day
instead he's like I don't know what goes
into paying off a porn star I'm not
going to be involved in this and I just
thought that was particularly weak in
turn you know so
um what do I like about Trump the reason
I vote for him not because I think he's
the greatest leader we've ever had I
think his foreign policy has been
absolutely fantastic considering the
presidents we've had in the past Obama
like blown up kids like Abdullahi a 16
year old American citizen we murdered
anyway uh Donald Trump's gonna fire
everybody he wants revenge and I think
if the one thing I can get out of the
next presidency is the purging of the of
the bureaucratic class this country will
be better off for it I don't know if
Rhonda Sanders would do that I think
he's a negotiator I think he's going to
go in and say how can we make this clean
and and it's going to be like Trump's
first term all over again they're going
to attack him they're going to smear him
they're going to lie they're going to
get their key positioned people to to
sludge everything up I think at this
point with Donald Trump he's he's
Unleashed he's so angry he's been
slighted he's been lied about they've
impeached him they're trying to
criminally uh process they're
Prosecuting him in in New York they're
trying to get him in DC they're trying
to get him in Georgia now they're
accusing him of a 30 year old rape case
I mean these people are Relentless and
almost every single time these stories
turn to be fake or even worse it's them
I mean the alpha Bank Russia stuff was a
lie Trump being a Soviet asset Jonathan
chick congratulations that was the most
ridiculous thing I've ever heard on
cable TV all of it a lie Ukraine gate
Joe Biden saying if you don't fight the
prosecutor you're not getting a billion
dollars which he admitted to at a CF
Army meeting
everything they say about Trump turns
out to be a misconstrued I think Trump
gets a like that he walks in and says I
don't care how I don't care uh uh why we
are going to terminate these people
we're going to send them out with nice
little boxes full of their belongings
and we're going to we're going to figure
out how to do it he wants to schedule a
laugh
that's the number one thing this country
needs right now I don't think DeSantis
does it so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]